Racism is not
I don't like this person or this group of people,
it is 1 group dominates 1 other group,
by justifying
This is because the other group is less human,
and that's important once we understand it.
Tokainism,
it is also in the perception we have of this group.
The racialized group,
it is the group that does not have the right to individuality.
That is, we,
as a racialized person,
we always represent
our group and we are,
we note,
we are always responsible for the
actions of our group.
When there is 1 racialized person
in its movements in climate
et cetera,
erra,
mstream or mostly white,
very often it closes the door to others because
because it is not perceived as 1 individual,
but as the representative of his group,
the dominant group will say,
that's enough,
We have our quota check.
There are people
that raise the question of intersectionality,
the real one,
that is to say the one that puts in the center
class issues,
race genre,
and then other issues that were added.
We see that in the climate movements,
we can
have organizations that are starting to think about
these questions,
try to integrate them
and try to take them into consideration.
At 1 moment,
this climate movement,
it will have to
position yourself
and that means that there will have to be 1 cleavage
between those who accept that,
at the origin of the climate crisis,
there is racism,
sexism,
classism and capitalism and those who reject it.
This movement,
it will have to position itself and therefore be split.